Hey youtubers, happy Wholock Week.
The game is on!
This week I’ll be alternating Doctor Who
and Sherlock videos every day in honor of
the Christmas Special and Sherlock Series
3.
Everything will be a mixture of fun list videos,
easter egg videos and reviews of the Christmas
Special, the Sherlock Mini Episode and Q and
As where I answer all your best questions
in a video.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
if you want me to answer your questions in
those Q&A videos be sure to write them in
the comments.
Just to get the party started here are my
TOP 10 Sherlock Moments So Far:
Number 10 - Jim From IT during the great game
I was totally fooled the first time I met
Jim from IT, the scene takes a whole different
context once you find out Jim is really James.
It’s a perfect blend of the unintentional
humor of Sherlock breaking down a person’s
attributes, Moriarty baiting him with a false
identity and onlookers like Molly and Watson
completely embarrassed by the whole experience.
It’s awkward Sherlock comedy at it’s best.
9 The Mind Palace from the Hound of Baskerville.
I love how Watson is always making fun of
Sherlock for not knowing loose facts about
mundane things.
The Mind Palace is his answer to all that.
If you’re not familiar with memory enhancement,
it’s a real thing.
They’re called mnemonic devices and they
give people ways to store large amounts of
information in their brains.
The other side of that is recall devices and
memory triggers.
Storing memories using mnemonic devices is
one thing, but using a word or a smell or
a phrase to recall a memory is the key to
finding things inside the mind palace.
When you see the graphics pop up around Sherlock’s
head, what you’re seeing are his recall
devices that help him find the information
he’s looking for inside his head.
8 Whipping the corpse during a study in pink.
This was our first introduction to Benedict
Cumberbatch’s sherlock.
It totally explained the character in a few
strokes of the riding crop.
Unlike Robert Downey Jr’s vagabond savant
approach to the character, Cumberbatch’s
Sherlock is hyper focused, intense and deceptively
asexual.
If you ever wanted to explain sherlock to
someone who had never seen it before.
Just show them this scene.
7 The very bloody mess during Hound of Baskerville.
The episode itself wasn’t my favorite, but
the reason I loved this moment so much was
that it gave you a real sense that some of
their most epic cases were happening in between
episodes.
All it takes is one look at sherlock covered
in blood and a few cursory words about having
to ride the tube and your mind explodes into
this pocket universe where we actually get
to see the case he just worked.
I like to think of it as the greater tales
of Sherlock as told by watson via his blog.
If you’re not familiar with the Conan Doyle
Sherlock stories, most of them are told in
first person by Watson as if being told after
they had all happened.
So Watson’s blog is the current version
of the character slowly writing the conan
doyle book The Adventures of Sherlock Holmes.
For anyone that’s curious, that bloody spear
is a reference to the conan doyle story The
Adventures of Black Peter.
6 Sherlock’s Standoff With Moriarty in The
Great Game.
I loved the way this episode ended and the
ambiguity of Sherlock’s intentions.
It’s always a game of chess with those two,
but would he have shot the explosives if Moriarty
had called his bluff?
After seeing how fast Sherlock’s mind works
in Scandal in Belgravia I definitely think
he had formulated a plan of how to survive
the explosion had he pulled the trigger.
That idea, planning for catastrophic events,
is crucial to how he survived the fall in
reichenbach fall.
5 Irene Adler’s Battle Suit in Scandal in
Belgravia.
It’s not so much the suit that was memorable,
it was Irene watching sherlock try to break
her down, while she was breaking him down.
The universe tells us that these two people
need to be together, but because of who they
are it ultimately ends in tragedy, even though
I felt the ending of the episode was optimistic.
Or at least left room for her return.
Amanda Abbington as Mary Morstan during season
3 is going to have a hard time matching Laura
Pulver’s Irene in season 2.
4 Buckingham Palace and pants during A Scandal
In Belgravia.
So many moments from this episode, but the
bedsheet and the banter with Mycroft was so
much fun.
Just like the explosives in great game and
the roof jump in reichenbach fall, I definitely
think he would have just keep walking.
And casually strolled out of buckingham palace
naked.
Let me know below in the comments how far
you think sherlock would have walked outside
naked before the queens guard tackled him.
3 Moriarty steals the Crown Jewels in Reichenbach
fall.
You don’t get to see a lot of Moriarty’s
process, but I loved the way he was so casual
about the whole thing.
Once you learn why he did it that part becomes
less of a mystery, but no one on this show
has more fun than Moriarty.
Sherlock and Watson have fun and Sherlock
definitely feels this intense satisfaction
when he solves puzzles, but I don’t think
he experiences pure joy in the way Moriarty
does when he’s misbehaving.
That would make a great spinoff show, Boys
Misbehaving starring Andrew Scott.
2 The Rooftop Fall in Reichenbach Fall.
You really do feel like it’s the end.
But the experience of the explosives in scandal
and the bedsheet and all of sherlock’s other
gambits kind of make you feel like he’s
going to get up and dust himself off.
So when I saw him lying there on the pavement
my heart kind of leapt out of my throat.
The whole episode had this air of finality
to it, mostly because of the watson scene
at the beginning, but also because when they
filmed it the series hadn’t been renewed
for a third yet.
So you didn’t know what was going to happen.
I’ll actually be doing a separate video
breaking down how I think he survived the
fall.
and my number one moment The Reveal at Sherlock’s
Grave in Reichenbach fall.
You had just gone through this intense experience,
so when the camera pans away to a very much
alive sherlock it was this giant WTF moment.
Remember, the series hadn’t been renewed
yet, so people had no idea if the fall would
ever be explained.
Just FYI though, that will not be the case
this season.
I mean, I totally expect it to end on a huge
cliffhanger, but both benedict cumberbatch
and martin freeman are under contract for
a fourth series.
But no filming date has been announced, so
hopefully we won’t have to wait two more
years like last time.
Like I said, I’ll be doing a breakdown of
how I think he survived the fall tomorrow.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Lots more Doctor Who coming this week too.
It’s a full week of Wholock content on my
channel.
You can click here to get that Breakdown of
how he survived, i’ll add the annotation
as soon as i post the video tomorrow.
and click here if you want spoilers for season
3.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!